Im Tessin, in einem abgelegenen
Seitental des Maggiatals,
liegt ganz hinten
die Alp Munt La Reita.
Nur einen Steinwurf von der
italienischen Grenze entfernt.
Verena und Markus Senn
aus dem Kanton Zürich
beginnen hier oben
in den 80er-Jahren,
als Aussteiger
ihren Lebenstraum umzusetzen.
Wir sind sog. 68er.
Und in dieser Bewegung, die ja
weltweit um sich gegriffen hat,
hat man gesehen,
dass neue Lebensformen wichtig sind.
Wir wollten nicht dagegen
demonstrieren oder dagegen sein,
sondern für etwas.
Deshalb haben wir versucht,
hier oben mit einem
Bergbauernprojekt anzufangen.
Die Folge war,
dass wir uns mit der Familie
in die Berge begeben haben.
Wir konnten Grund und Boden kaufen
und auf diesem Land
eine Bergheimat aufbauen -
ganz nach unserem Geschmack,
mit Tieren, der Natur und in
Harmonie, soweit dies möglich ist.
1986 ziehen Verena und Markus Senn
mit ihren sechs Kindern ins Tessin.
Hier, auf über 1'400 m,
gibt es nichts ausser der Natur.
Die Familie schläft in Tipis.
Improvisation ist angesagt.
Wir hatten
überhaupt keine Infrastruktur,
weder eine Zufahrt noch Wasser
oder Elektrizität, gar nichts.
Ausser den drei Steinhütten
hatten wir nichts.
Wir hatten Waschbecken
und haben uns draussen gewaschen.
Mit kaltem Wasser natürlich,
aber daran gewöhnt man sich.
Ich habe Brot gebacken.
Den Teig
machte ich in einer Holzkiste
und ich hatte einen kleinen Ofen.
Wir assen morgens, mittags
und abends in der Freiluftküche -
egal, ob das Wetter
gut oder schlecht war.
Und ...
Im Herbst ist man fast erfroren.
Ja, im Oktober wurde es kühler.
Bei 3 °C sagten wir:
"Wir müssen etwas ändern."
Ja, ja.
Ein Wohnhaus hat Priorität.
Aber den Tessiner Behörden
missfallen die Baupläne.
Verzweifelt wenden sich Verena
und Markus Senn an die Medien.
Das Schweizer Fernsehen und die
Zeitschrift "Beobachter" berichten.
Viele Leute haben
auf diese Medienberichte reagiert,
sie haben geschrieben.
Danach ist es
vorwärtsgegangen mit der Käserei,
dann konnten wir wirklich
Käse produzieren.
Es gab genügend Käufer für den Käse.
Die Leute
haben uns auch unterstützt,
indem sie gekommen sind
und mitgeholfen haben,
sei es beim Heuen oder beim Bauen.
Das war immer sehr wertvoll.
Markus und Verena Senn
sind gezwungen, aufwendiger zu bauen,
als sie es wollten.
Denn ohne minimale Betriebsgrösse
erhalten sie keine Subventionen.
Die Grösse dieses Hofes
ist mit den Jahren entstanden.
Von Anfang an hatten wir nie riesige
Sachen geplant, überhaupt nicht.
Nein, wir wollten
klein und bescheiden bleiben.
Aber als wir mit den Behörden
in Kontakt gekommen sind,
als wir sagten,
dass wir bauen wollen ...
Die Kühe mussten ja irgendwohin,
und wir mussten irgendwo wohnen.
Die Behörden haben dann bezüglich
der Grösse Vorgaben gemacht,
weil sie meinten, dass sonst
keine Existenz möglich sei.
Das begreife ich auch,
sie können ja nichts
subventionieren oder bewilligen,
von dem sie von Anfang an wissen,
dass es nicht rentabel sein kann.
Wir waren also fast gezwungen,
einen Stall für 14 Kühe zu bauen.
Heute steht der Hof dort,
wo die Familie am Anfang
ihre Tipis aufgestellt hatte.
Munt La Reita ist einer von
über 300 Bio-Bergbauern-Betrieben,
die sich in der Gesellschaft
Bergheimat organisiert haben.
Zum Hof gehört ein grosser Garten.
Was sie nicht selbst brauchen,
verkauft Verena Senn
auf dem Markt in Locarno.
Es brauchte viel Mut und sie wussten:
Ohne Knochenarbeit
würde ihr Traum nicht funktionieren.
Als wir hierherkamen, waren wir
ja kein unbeschriebenes Blatt.
Wir sind Macher.
Die Kleine war halbjährig,
als wir hier angefangen haben,
der Älteste war 13.
Wer konnte, hat mit angepackt.
Wohin?
Alle Kinder sind erwachsen und
mit einer Ausnahme längst ausgezogen.
Zusammen mit den Eltern lebt heute
noch Sohn Sämi auf dem Hof.
Wir sechs Goofen
waren eine schöne Rasselbande.
Verena und Markus,
also meine Eltern,
waren immer
mit dem Aufbau beschäftigt,
das war nicht einfach.
Sie hatten nicht
sehr viel Zeit für uns.
Wir mussten natürlich
immer mithelfen,
sonst wäre das Ganze
nicht so gross geworden.
Aber ... Ja ...
Wir waren einfach ein Baugeschäft.
Wir haben gearbeitet und gewerkelt.
Wir sind am Morgen aufgestanden
und haben
die Betonmaschine eingeschaltet.
Nach dem Frühstück
haben wir weitergemacht.
Wir hielten uns stets
an ein Programm.
Als Kind macht man einfach mit.
Man musste einfach.
Die Eltern haben etwas angefangen
und die Kinder haben mitgemacht.
Man denkt nicht darüber nach,
ob einem das passt oder nicht.
Wir wussten zwar,
dass unsere Schulkollegen
im Sommer in die Ferien fuhren.
Sie erzählten uns,
dass sie am Meer waren.
Da dachte ich manchmal schon:
"Super, wir haben
den ganzen Sommer gearbeitet."
Und dann wird es schwierig ...
Wenn man nicht vergleichen kann
und nichts anderes kennt,
denkt man gar nicht daran, dass es
noch andere Möglichkeiten gäbe.
Man funktioniert einfach
und wächst so auf,
das ist deine Welt.
* Muhen *
Ein Abhang hinter dem Hof
wird im Winter zur Rennstrecke.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Es sind seltene Momente,
in denen die Familie es schafft,
den Alltag beiseitezulassen.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Als Hobbyfilmer dokumentiert Markus
auch das Leben neben der Arbeit.
Feriengäste, Helfer und die Familie
stehen dann im Mittelpunkt.
Du kannst die Sieben
nicht mehr spielen.
* Volksmusik *
* Beschwingte Musik *
Kommt!
Barbara, das jüngste der sechs
Kinder, hat den Hof mit 16 verlassen,
um eine Ausbildung
als Tourismusfachfrau zu starten.
Sie lebt heute in der Stadt Zürich.
Meine ersten Erinnerungen sind stark
mit Tieren, mit Pferden verbunden,
und mit dem Gefühl, frei zu sein.
Heute lebe ich in der Stadt
und kann davon kaum etwas sehen.
Die Kinder hier sind sehr stark
auf die Eltern fixiert,
während wir die meiste Zeit
draussen verbracht haben.
Daran erinnere ich mich gut, wenn
ich an Munt la Reita zurückdenke.
Die Gefühle waren vielleicht schon
der Tagesstruktur untergeordnet.
Wichtig war, dass das Hofleben lief.
Wir mussten wirklich
viele Arbeiten erledigen.
Aber es gab auch
immer wieder Momente,
in denen man sich selber sein
oder sich zurückziehen konnte.
Ich ging immer
zu unserem Pferd Jeannette,
legte mich auf den Rücken
und verbrachte so den Nachmittag.
Einfach sein.
Im Dorf Cimalmotto,
2 km unterhalb der Alp,
rieben sich die letzten
verbliebenen Einwohner die Augen,
als die Deutschschweizer
ins abgelegene Tal einwanderten.
Die Einheimischen wussten nicht,
wie sie uns einordnen sollten.
Sie haben ihren Kindern
stets empfohlen,
in die Stadt zu gehen,
etwas zu werden,
das harte Leben
hinter sich zu lassen.
Und dann kommt
eine Familie mit sechs Kindern
und macht das Gegenteil.
Das hat den Leuten zu denken gegeben
und sie haben uns lange beobachtet.
Manchmal waren sie freundlich,
manchmal waren sie
weniger freundlich.
Wir durften uns
überhaupt nichts erlauben,
was aus ihrer Sicht
nicht der Norm entsprach.
Sonst hat man uns das spüren lassen.
Wir mussten sehr feinfühlig sein,
um uns integrieren zu können.
Die Tiere, wir -
wir waren alle in einem Gebäude.
Entsprechend hat alles
den gleichen Geruch angenommen.
Das haben die Leute im Tal unten
nicht verstanden.
Um 6 Uhr mussten wir aufstehen
und ins Dorf laufen.
Dann sind wir eine Stunde
mit dem Schulbus gefahren.
Im Bus machten wir Hausaufgaben
oder lernten für Prüfungen.
Als Deutschschweizer im Tessin
und Bergbauernsohn
bin ich immer gehänselt worden.
Früher hatten ja
nur arme Leute so gelebt.
All diese Dinge zusammen
haben mich schon ein wenig ... Ja.
Aber ich habe mich durchgeschlagen.
* Melodiöse Klaviermusik *
Verena, die ehemalige Buchhändlerin,
und Markus,
der gelernte Schriftsetzer,
sind im AHV-Alter angekommen.
Buon appetito.
Seit der 68er-Bewegung
sind sie ein Paar.
Das muss ich am Nachmittag
noch machen.
Und unten?
- Müssen sie auch abdecken.
* Popsong "Heavenly Club"
von Les Sauterelles *
Die Hippies aus den USA
machen es vor.
Der alternative Lebensstil
wird auch in der Schweiz zum Thema.
Neue Formen des Zusammenlebens
werden ausprobiert.
Markus und Verena hinterfragen Kon-
sumdenken und Wirtschaftswachstum
und wollen der zunehmenden Umwelt-
zerstörung etwas entgegensetzen.
Das ist das Lebensbuch
von Verena und mir,
es trägt das Symbol
des Lebensbaums.
Hier wollten wir eigentlich unsere
ganze Lebensgeschichte aufschreiben,
bebildern und illustrieren.
Leider sind wir aber
nicht sehr weit gekommen.
Wir haben das
einige Jahre lang gemacht,
aber dann, wie es so ist,
wenn man viele Projekte hat,
war oft etwas anderes wichtiger
und wir haben nicht am Buch
weitergearbeitet.
Deshalb ist das Lebensbuch
noch relativ dünn.
Wichtig ist auf jeden Fall,
dass wir in dieser Gesellschaft
einen anderen Weg gesucht haben.
Wir hatten einfach Probleme
mit gewissen Dingen,
wie alle 68er damals.
Wir hatten in Zürich gewohnt, wir
wollten das Stadtleben ausprobieren.
Eigentlich sind wir vom Land.
In der Stadt
merkten wir bald einmal,
dass das nicht unser Ding ist.
Zu Beginn der 70er-Jahre
wohnten Verena und Markus
in einem besetzten Haus
an der Venedig-Strasse in Zürich.
Die Strasse
existiert heute nicht mehr.
Was sehe ich da? Schau dir das an!
Wo die Venedig-Strasse war,
steht jetzt ein riesiger Komplex.
Und von wem? Von der FIFA.
Unglaublich! Unglaublich!
Ja ...
- Ausgerechnet die!
Die Stadt verkaufte die Strasse
samt den historischen Gebäuden
an einen privaten Investor.
Um den Abbruch der Häusergruppe
zu verhindern,
kam es zu Protestaktionen.
Markus und Verena demonstrieren mit.
Was wir an der Venedig-Strasse
brauchen,
ist Essen und Material
und die Mittel ...
Danach ist unser Weg weitergegangen.
Wir haben dann mit den Bergleuten
im Wallis auf 1'800 m ü.M.
ein Camp gemacht.
Dort sind wir so richtig
auf einen Indianer-Trip gekommen.
Wir versuchten, autark zu leben.
Wir haben Steinhütten gebaut
und die mit Transparenten bespannt.
Die Transparente stammten
von einer Umweltdemo in Zürich
und dienten uns als Dach.
Wir haben sie mit Leinöl bestrichen
und die Steinhütten damit gedeckt.
Jeder baute
seine individuelle Hütte.
Es gab auch eine Gemeinschaftsküche.
Wir haben den ganzen Sommer
dort verbracht
und das öffentlich gemacht.
D.h., dass interessierte Leute
zu uns kommen konnten.
Ich bin dort in die Aufgabe
des Kräuterdoktors hineingewachsen.
Ich hatte
überhaupt keine Vorbildung.
Ich hatte ein Buch
von Pfarrer Künzle
und begann hobbymässig
Kräuter zu sammeln.
Ich dachte nicht, dass ich das
ernsthaft brauchen könnte.
Aber wo es Menschen gibt,
gibt es auch
gesundheitliche Probleme.
Deshalb haben wir das
dann ausprobiert.
* Rocksong "Morning Dew"
von Krokodil *
# I thought I heard a young girl cry.
# I thought I heard a young girl cry
today.
# You didn't hear no young girl cry.
Eines Tages
kam plötzlich die Polizei.
Sie sagten, sie hätten den Auftrag,
das Camp zu räumen.
Sie nahmen uns allen die Pässe weg
und begannen,
uns einzeln zu verhören.
Einer sagte: "Senn."
Ich machte keinen Wank,
ich sass einfach am Boden.
"Senn!"
Da stand ich auf und sagte:
"Wenn ihr mutig genug seid,
stelle ich mich an diesen Pfahl
und ihr könnt mich erschiessen."
"Ich komme nicht."
Da war Schluss.
Sie packten zusammen und gingen,
aber unsere Pässe nahmen sie mit.
Das war eine sehr interessante,
lebhafte Zeit.
Aber wir haben dann
schon auch gesehen,
dass wir eigentlich
doch noch nicht so
gemeinschaftsfähig waren,
wie wir uns das eigentlich
vorgestellt hatten.
Es kamen ja alle aus
Einfamilienhäuschen-Situationen.
Man wusste nicht,
wie man gemeinschaftlich
funktionieren sollte.
Die Vorsätze waren ideal,
aber eben,
wie es so ist mit diesen Idealen,
die Umsetzung ist etwas anderes,
v.a. auch, in so einem Tal
überhaupt Fuss fassen zu können.
Ja ...
Die Vision war schon grossartig.
* Vögel zwitschern. *
Dass wir dort hinaufgingen,
war schon eine Art Flucht,
das gebe ich zu.
Wir hatten uns einfach
nicht zugetraut,
in der damaligen Gesellschaft
sechs Kinder durchzubringen,
ohne diese ...
Oder vielleicht
waren wir auch zu feige
und wollten einfach nicht die
Schwierigkeiten in Kauf nehmen ...
Also ich habe nicht so gedacht.
Ich wollte, dass die Kinder wissen,
woher die Nahrungsmittel kommen
und was man dafür tun kann."
Und das Feeling
mit den Tieren und der Natur ...
Das war schon meine Priorität.
- Ja, ja, das war natürlich ...
Der Grund war nicht einfach,
dass es in den Betonstädten trostlos
und wenig erbaulich für Kinder ist.
Und mit sechs Kindern
braucht man schon Freiraum -
und den hatten sie natürlich.
Alles hat immer zwei Seiten,
immer, überall, das ist schon klar.
Was bei ihnen
gesellschaftlich-sozial zu kurz kam,
konnten sie mit andern Erlebnissen
kompensieren.
Und handwerklich sind sie ...
Sie können alles.
Dank dem Hof und meinen Eltern
habe ich sehr viele Fähigkeiten.
Es gab positive
und weniger positive Momente.
Ich bin wahnsinnig stolz ...
90 % der Dinge, die ich kann,
kann ich, weil ich dort oben
aufgewachsen bin.
Und meistens sage ich auch,
dass ich käsen und melken kann.
Das ist für mich immer so ein ...
Hi!
Als einziges der sechs Senn-Kinder
hat Sämi eine landwirtschaftliche
Ausbildung abgeschlossen
und kommt damit am ehesten
als Nachfolger auf dem Hof infrage.
Sämi hätte Lust, in Zukunft
auch Berghonig zu produzieren.
Sie müssen hier ...
Anfang Juli
haben wir die Bienen geholt.
Nun haben wir den Prototypen
eines Bienenkastens gebaut.
Mal schauen, wie sich das bewährt.
Ich weiss gar nicht, ob sie
noch da sind, ich sehe nichts.
So!
Mal sehen,
ob sie mich reinschauen lassen.
* Summen *
* Muhen *
Ihr müsst sie nicht fangen,
nur anlocken.
Gibi, gibi, gibi ...
Die anderen
müsst ihr noch hinausscheuchen.
Das Bergleben ist hart,
alles andere als idyllisch.
Wer es Tag für Tag lebt,
kennt auch die Schattenseiten.
Am Anfang finden es alle schön
und sagen:
"Juhui, das ist das Paradies."
Aber es braucht mind. ein Probejahr.
Den Winter muss man auch erleben.
Man ist immer angebunden
mit den Tieren,
man arbeitet jeden Tag,
es gibt keine Wochenenden ...
Wenn ich trainieren
oder jemanden treffen will,
muss ich pro Weg
mind. eine Stunde autofahren.
Damit habe ich ein wenig Mühe.
Hier ist ja sonst nichts los.
Also ...
Im Winter bist du alleine.
* Sanfte Musik *
Fürs Käsen ist Verena verantwortlich.
Seit 30 Jahren verarbeitet sie
jeden Morgen 150 l Milch.
Wenn ich den Ofen öffne,
gelangt manchmal etwas Asche hinein.
Aber Asche macht nichts.
Das sind jetzt die Beilagen,
wir nennen das einfach so.
Jetzt darf man den Kessel
nicht mehr anfassen,
es darf sich nichts mehr bewegen.
Voila!
Einen Teil des Alpkäses
verschickt Verena per Post
an eine treue Kundschaft
in der ganzen Schweiz.
Bald werden die Senns
die Produktion aufgeben müssen.
Die Arbeit ist zu streng
und zu aufwendig.
Sonst setzt sich das bald.
Kann ich schon?
- Jawohl.
Ein freies, selbstbestimmtes Leben
haben sie gesucht
und teilweise auch gefunden.
Aber Markus kämpft immer häufiger
mit Depressionen.
Ich hatte nächtelang
ein Karussell im Kopf,
das ich einfach nicht
stoppen konnte.
Mir gingen ständig die gleichen
Gedanken durch den Kopf,
obwohl ich längst schlafen wollte.
Aber es ging einfach nicht.
Schwierig war
Markus' gesundheitlicher Zustand,
das war sehr prägend.
Wir haben natürlich immer ...
Aufgrund der Depressionen,
die er jahrzehntelang hatte,
mussten wir immer ...
Wir mussten uns immer
entsprechend verhalten.
So sind wir aufgewachsen.
Er hat tagelang geschwiegen,
wollte nicht essen
und hat sich verkrochen.
Da fragt man sich,
was man tun kann.
Das machte mir schon zu schaffen.
Während des Aufbaus
von Munt la Reita
hatte er gar keine Gelegenheit,
einmal sagen zu können:
"Ich mache mal
eine Woche lang Ferien."
Ich glaube, sie waren bis heute
nicht auf Hochzeitsreise,
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Sie haben geheiratet,
sind ins Tessin gegangen
und haben 30 Jahre lang
durchgearbeitet.
Das hat Spuren hinterlassen,
v.a. bei ihm.
Aber das ist gut nachvollziehbar.
* Sanfte Musik *
Markus und Verena Senn haben Sorgen.
Um die Zukunft für den Hof
zu sichern,
muss die Nachfolge geregelt sein.
Ja, ich muss sagen,
dass wir in den letzten Wochen sind.
Das hängt mit der Übergabe
und Umstellung des Hofes zusammen.
Ein Auge weint, eines lacht.
Es ist nicht einfach, aber ...
Ja.
Ich kann es akzeptieren, wie es ist.
Ich habe ein gutes Gefühl,
wenn ich zurückschaue.
Ja, es ist gut so.
* Muhen *
Sämi möchte den Betrieb umstellen:
von Milchkuh-Haltung
auf Mutterkuh-Haltung.
Dies bedeutet, die Kälber bleiben
nach der Geburt bei der Mutter,
die Milchproduktion fällt weg.
Eine Überlegung war, dass das Käsen
bei dieser Grösse nicht rentiert.
Ich kann ja nicht alles
alleine machen.
Wenn man das ganze Drum und Dran
inkl. Käsepflege berücksichtigt,
ist Käsen ein Vollzeitjob.
Ich müsste also jemanden einstellen.
Die Einnahmen würden dann gerade
den Lohn decken.
Da der Hof
immer im Hintergrund existiert hat,
habe ich mir nie wirklich
gross Gedanken gemacht,
unabhängig vom Hof
selbstständig zu werden
oder mir
eine eigene Existenz aufzubauen.
Aber da die Pensionierung der Eltern
immer näherkommt,
ist es immer konkreter geworden.
Eigentlich könnten Verena und Markus
stolz sein auf das,
was sie geschaffen haben.
Aber Sämis Zögern,
den Hof zu übernehmen, bedrückt.
Die Unsicherheit von Sämi -
will er überhaupt?
Bei ihm ist klar, dass er das
nur der Familie zuliebe tut.
Aber jetzt macht er es ...
- Ganz definitiv ist es noch nicht.
Er will Ende September entscheiden,
hat aber bereits
entsprechende Zeichen gegeben.
Für uns ist es etwas mühsam
zu sehen,
dass er es nicht
aus 100%iger Überzeugung macht.
Er braucht die Garantie,
dass er seine Freiheiten hat.
Und das würden wir schon sehen.
Das ruft aber wieder uns
auf den Plan.
Ja, aber nur zeitweise, nicht immer.
Ich habe das Problem, dass es mich -
wie es jetzt auch der Fall ist -
dass es mich wieder
richtig reinzieht, mit allem.
Man sollte sagen können:
"Hier ist die Grenze, hier bin ich."
Es ist dieser Schritt,
der so schwierig ist.
Ich bin einfach noch nicht so weit.
Er kann das noch nicht vollziehen.
Dann lässt er jeweils
den Kopf hängen, ist ja klar.
Und ich sehe das natürlich.
Ich kann mich besser abgrenzen.
Ich kann hier sein und Freude haben,
ohne zu denken:
"Eigentlich sollte ich dies und das
auch noch erledigen."
Sämi ist 42 und wünscht sich
eine eigene Familie.
Eine Partnerin zu finden, die hier
oben leben möchte, ist schwierig.
Was, wenn ich meine ganze Energie
in den Hof stecke,
etwas daraus mache,
und dann meine Frau kommt und sagt:
"Wir müssen gehen,
das geht so nicht."
Dann ...
Da frage ich mich manchmal schon,
ob ich das überhaupt
alleine machen soll.
Würde ich allein hierbleiben,
es alleine machen?
Oder würde ich
spätestens dann gehen?
Für wen
hätte ich dann alles gemacht?
Das sind Fragen,
die kommen und gehen.
Ja.
* Volkstümliche Melodie von
Max Lässer & Das Überlandorchester *
Die ungelöste Hofnachfolge
und der Alltagsdruck werden zu viel.
Ausgerechnet an seinem Geburtstag
bricht Markus zusammen.
Die Ambulanz bringt ihn ins Spital.
Es ist schwierig,
wenn man als Bergbauer zugeben muss,
dass man auch als Bergbauer
ein Burn-out bekommen kann,
während Manager
und gestresste Wirtschaftsleute
in die Berge gehen,
um sich zu erholen,
damit sie kein Burn-out erleiden.
Und ich musste dann einfach ...
Ich musste mir einfach eingestehen:
Wenn einem etwas Freude macht,
auch eine alternative Sache,
und man sich so stark
damit identifiziert,
sich voll reinkniet und es unbedingt
gut oder noch besser machen will,
kommt man in die genau gleiche
Situation wie ein Manager.
Ich hatte tage- und v.a. nächtelang
ein sog. Karussell.
Aber ich bin nie
auf die Idee gekommen,
dass etwas Ernstes
dahinterstecken könnte.
Ich sagte: "Komm, weitermachen!
Kopf runter und rennen."
So hat man es gelernt,
ja keine Schwäche zeigen.
Aber eben ...
Irgendwann ist es dann
doch zu viel geworden.
Der Körper, die Psyche -
alles war überfordert.
Und als das passiert ist,
habe ich eigentlich wirklich ...
... gesehen,
dass es eine Hölle gibt.
Seither weiss ich,
was es bedeutet,
wenn Menschen
sich umbringen wollen -
aus Verzweiflung,
aus Panik, aus Angst,
aus den verschiedensten Gründen.
Ich wurde nicht davon verschont.
Hätte ich die Unterstützung
meiner Frau nicht gehabt,
wäre ich vermutlich nicht mehr hier.
Das ist etwas,
das man nicht aushalten kann,
es übersteigt einfach
die menschlichen Kräfte.
Bei Freunden im Zürcher Weinland
tankt Markus Kraft für die Rückkehr.
Verena, die Kinder und Freunde
halten unterdessen auf Munt La Reita
die Stellung.
Wir haben viele Therapeuten
kennengelernt
und viele gute Gespräche geführt.
Manchmal wusste wir nicht,
wie es weitergehen soll,
dann mussten wir uns neu ausrichten.
Wenn er im Spital war,
habe ich ihn dort besucht.
So haben wir das überstanden.
Ich habe mich auch
spirituell ausgerichtet,
sonst wäre es wohl nicht gegangen.
Es ist so, dass eine Verzweiflung
schnell kommen kann,
wenn man nicht mehr weiss,
wie es weitergehen soll.
Und dann muss man versuchen,
loszulassen.
Eigentlich hat man alles Nötige
in sich selber.
Man hat Regenerationskräfte,
Heilkräfte,
Kräfte, die bewirken,
dass es dir trotzdem gut geht.
Und es darf dir ja auch gut gehen.
Leben bedeutet nicht leiden.
All das konnte ich
in mir selbst mobilisieren
und ich habe versucht,
es weiterzugeben.
Er hat auf seine Art
daran gearbeitet.
So hat sich vieles
zum Guten gewendet.
Im Nachhinein denke ich,
dass nichts umsonst war.
Wir mussten all diese Dinge
durchstehen,
um geistige Reife zu erlangen.
Anders kann ich es nicht erklären.
Es war ein intensiver, mühsamer Weg,
aber ich weiss,
dass es nicht so passiert wäre,
wenn es nicht so hätte sein sollen.
Es musste sein, damit jeder von uns
auf seinem persönlichen Weg
eine Schulung durchmachen konnte -
auch unsere Jungen.
Für mich war es
eine ganz wichtige Zeit
und ich fühle mich jetzt
eigentlich gut.
So, finito.
Gefühlsmässig ist Verena
eine sehr grosse Stütze.
Das war ein wichtiger Punkt,
so konnte Markus sich fallenlassen.
Sie war immer die Stärkste von uns.
Wenn man Verena
mal hat weinen sah,
dann wusste man:
"Jetzt ist es gar nicht mehr gut."
Ich erinnere mich, dass ich diesen
Eindruck schon als Kind hatte.
Und es ist heute noch so.
Wir hatten
ein sehr hochgestecktes Ziel
und wir wussten nicht,
ob wir es je erreichen würden.
Unser Fokus
lag immer nur auf diesem Ziel,
aber wir dachten nie daran,
was nachher sein würde.
Man kann es
mit einer Bergwanderung vergleichen:
Wir dachten nur an den Aufstieg,
aber nie an den Abstieg.
Deshalb sind wir jetzt auch
herausgefordert,
eine Lösung, einen Weg zu finden.
* Rhythmische Klänge *
Das sieht ja wieder aus ...
- Es ist immer das Gleiche.
Es geht zwar noch.
Jetzt habe ich ins Dach gehakt.
Voila!
Hoppla!
- Schon unten.
Nach längerer Auszeit
ist Markus endlich zurück im Tessin
und will wieder Tritt fassen.
Einfach ist das nicht.
Die schweren Gedanken
sind immer noch da.
In den letzten zwei Monaten
fand v.a. die Hofübergabe statt.
Damit hatten wir uns ja
recht lange schwergetan.
Schlussendlich
hat's dann doch geklappt.
Jetzt sind wir alle
sehr froh und entlastet.
Ich habe den Hof
übernommen und unterschrieben,
jetzt schauen wir weiter.
Wir werden sehen,
wie es sich entwickelt
und was sich daraus ergibt.
Ich weiss noch nicht,
ob es klappen wird oder nicht.
Oh mein Gott,
hier sieht's ja auch aus ...
Man hat natürlich Verantwortung
für etwas Riesiges,
nicht nur für den Hof,
aber auch nach aussen,
gegenüber den Behörden, Banken usw.
Jetzt muss ich einfach schauen,
dass ich, dass ich ...
Wie soll ich das sagen?
... dass ich nicht
in die gleiche Situation komme
wie mein Vater damals,
sonst mache ich das nicht lange.
Keine Chance.
- Keine Chance?
Wow!
Gut, dass wir das ändern können.
- Schau mal!
Voila!
Ich muss ab und zu weg, immer dann,
wenn es mir zu brenzlig wird.
Der Grund ist das Burn-out,
das ich hatte.
Ich sage immer, dass es wie
ein Monster hinter einem Baum ist.
Es schaut hervor
und beobachtet dich.
Und wenn dein Energielevel tief ist
oder du überfordert bist,
dann schlägt es zu.
Sonst ist es jeweils vorne
in der Walze.
Es gibt schon einen Trick:
auf die Intuition hören.
Wenn die Intuition sagt,
man solle Yoga machen -
er z.B. macht das -
oder Langlauf oder Marathon -
das macht er auch, herumrennen.
Solange er das wahrnehmen kann,
was für sein Gemüt, für seine Seele
Nahrung ist,
läuft er nicht Gefahr,
ein Burn-out zu bekommen.
Wenn er die Möglichkeit hat,
rauszukommen ...
Deshalb wäre eine Gemeinschaft gut,
dann könnte er immer ersetzt werden.
Wenn man immer
nonstop dranbleiben muss -
das haben wir selber erlebt -
wenn man sogar mit Grippe
in den Stall melken gehen muss,
wenn eine Sekunde zur Stunde wird,
weil es einem so schlecht geht,
dann geht es an die Substanz.
Das sollte man möglichst vermeiden.
Kommt!
Komm!
Ein halbes Jahr später.
Mit den neuen Mutterkühen
geht es zum ersten Mal auf die Alp.
Der neue Chef
denkt über die Zukunft nach.
Ich muss noch vieles herausfinden.
Ideen gibt es viele,
man kann vieles machen:
Agrotourismus, Alpbetrieb,
ein Permakultur-Projekt,
das zustande kommt.
Es gibt verschiedene Bereiche.
Wir können Seminare für Gruppen
veranstalten.
Doch zuerst müssen wir alles
in Ordnung bringen.
Ich habe eine Baueingabe gemacht,
damit ich den Stall
und die Garage umbauen kann.
Zudem werde ich das Haus
energetisch sanieren.
Und es braucht
einige Umgebungsanpassungen.
Lukas, aufschliessen!
Die drehen um.
Jag sie mit aller Kraft rauf!
Hüa!
Bleibt dort! Hüa! Hopp! Allez! Hü!
Allez hopp!
Hüa! Jag sie hoch!
Komm! Ja, komm dazwischen,
das ist vielleicht besser.
Gut. Kannst du schauen,
dass alle raufgehen?
Einerseits bin ich hier oben bis
zu einem gewissen Grad glücklich,
aber manchmal merke ich,
dass mir etwas fehlt.
Ja ... Wie bringt man alles
unter einen Hut?
Denn auf die richtige Partnerin
wartet Sämi noch immer.
Meistens wollen sie,
dass ich ins Tal runtergehe,
hier ist es allen zu abgelegen,
zu weit weg.
Und wenn man noch mit den Eltern
im gleichen Haus wohnt,
ist es sowieso nicht einfach.
Jemand hat mir einmal gesagt, ich
sei mit Munt la Reita verheiratet.
Markus findet nun endlich Zeit
für ein Projekt,
von dem er schon seit Jahren träumt.
Jetzt kann er es umsetzen.
Komm, Sugi, Sugi Sugi, komm!
Hier entsteht ein Permakultur-Garten.
Permakultur orientiert sich
an den Kreisläufen der Natur.
Gute Ernteerträge
mit weniger Aufwand ist das Ziel.
Komm!
Das ist gut, nicht?
Das sind unsere Wühlnasen
und Mithelfer in der Permakultur.
Sie bereiten das Terrain
für uns vor,
damit wir nachher
Terrassen anlegen können
für Obst und Beeren.
Nicht wahr? Ja, ja.
Fest graben! Ja, fest graben!
Und ein Sonnenbad nehmen.
Gut. Macht's gut!
Mit der Permakultur
möchten wir erreichen,
dass wir uns eben nicht überfordern.
Aber das Einrichten und Gestalten
ist mit Knochenarbeit verbunden.
Aber wenn es einmal so weit ist,
werde ich auch
nicht immer hier sein,
sondern nur von Mai bis Juli,
bis das Heu eingebracht ist.
Nachher gibt es weniger zu tun.
* Beschauliche Musik *
Vor einem Monat
hatte es hier noch Schnee.
Ich bewundere meine Eltern
für so ziemlich alles,
aber ganz sicher dafür, dass sie
immer wieder aufgestanden sind,
dafür, dass sie immer wieder
Energie finden,
um etwas durchzuziehen.
Das machen heutzutage
nur noch wenige Leute.
Ob ich das nochmals
genau gleich machen würde?
Das könnte ich nicht einfach
mit Ja beantworten.
Es ist nicht so einfach.
Ich denke ...
Wenn ich mehr an die Kinder denke,
wenn man als Familie geht ...
Es war schon happig.
Wenn man das als Pioniere macht,
muss man schon gut überlegen,
wie man das handhaben will.
Wie weit will man gehen?
Wie lange ist der Schulweg?
Ja ... Es gibt schon Punkte,
die schwierig sind.
Oft hat man als Familie
auch nicht genug Zeit füreinander.
So gesehen würde ich es vielleicht
ein wenig sanfter angehen,
nicht mehr ganz so extrem.
Wenn ich jung und knusprig wäre
wie damals, vielleicht.
Vielleicht aber auch nicht.
Aber zum Glück weiss man am Anfang
nicht, was einem alles blüht.
Ja, ja, sonst würde man es
vielleicht besser bleiben lassen.
Nein, aber ...
Jetzt ist es eine erfreuliche Sache.
Und es geht weiter.
Das ist die Hauptsache.